so today's topic I'm gonna call up a
friend of mine sada I'm gonna get her to
create a tinder account using pictures
of me so she's gonna create a mail
account and then she's gonna have the
experience of trying to get women on
that app to date her sada is a smart
girl and she's pretty sympathetic to
male struggles so she probably
appreciates on a cognitive level that
this is not going to be easy that being
a man on one of these dating apps is not
easy but I'm curious to see her journey
as she actually goes through the
experience of being in a man shoes and
trying to chat up women all right let's
go ahead and give her a call nada how
are you doing I'm finding you yes I'm
doing very well I told you that I was
gonna have an experiment for you are you
are you ready are you feeling nervous
all right I'm ready I'm excited I guess
I'm excited let me first ask you have
you ever been on the dating app tinder
before yes okay so how was it as a woman
did you get lots of matches did lots of
men try and talk to you what I want to
do today is I want to swap your gender I
want to see what it's like if a woman is
put into the shoes of a man so I'm gonna
send you a couple of photos of myself
and I want you to create a dating
profile of course if you're a man and
you wanna talk to me and you say ah bah
oh that's a cute man ha I'm not even on
tinder and I know that's what it is
I know people want us to react to this
but I'm like I know where this is gonna
go yeah what do you want us to react to
we well I don't think that you're gonna
get that many matches I think that
you're gonna struggle I'm not doing any
false humility I understand I'm
reasonably like okay to look at like I'm
probably above average but I think that
you're still gonna find a lot of
difficulty okay this will be fun so
never really fully understand because we
have a whole lifetime so this issue and
her experience is not going to be a male
it's gonna be like a glimpse into you if
I'm going to put your pictures I mean
your looks are good you're attractive so
that will be easy like to match with
with women because they will anything
look at that yeah because of yeah
because of your looks
that's the face of a meze
you think really yeah okay it also
depends on where you are I like that
we've got an experiment and you've got a
hypothesis which says that you're gonna
get a lot of matches based on my
appearance
I promise I'll send you some good photos
of myself or at least I'll try and find
some here's also a good point men take
terrible photos you compare women's
photos on Instagram on social media on
dating profiles and you compared to men
it's like watching a caveman versus a
[ __ ] US Marine it's completely
different I don't think that she
realizes how difficult this is gonna be
the next step is I need to find some
photos to send her have no idea what
people put on their tinder photos but
I'm not gonna do a topless shot
everything I have a topless shot okay so
I think I've chosen the three photos
that I want to send her I'll show you
I've got this one that seems pretty
standard it's just a photo of me looking
at a camera I chose this one's from a
few years ago like a boat cruise that I
took and this one is kind of just to
troll her a little bit those are bad
photos he's sabotaging her I'm sorry but
this is sabotage that's sabotage to me
these last two photos weren't that great
the second will not give you it could
pass this last one I'm sorry no okay you
know what maybe I'm wrong
ladies but the ladies in the comments
what did you think of the last two
pictures but picture - I would have kind
of let pass okay picture three would you
have let us within again those pictures
are the average mr. oh that's on tinder
what are these jihadis doing on the bed
I don't look I thought it looks like an
r2 party for like Isis you're saying but
I've seen some pretty bad pictures on
that whatever we play give me your phone
and we just you know swipe the tinder
and everything and stuff you know the
guys like you said they take pretty bad
pictures that's average pictures for
tinder of a man yeah all right
it's honestly below average pictures the
first one was really good
the other two no sir those photos would
not have been a problem if he had more
photos of him that looked decent that
third photo for example it sounds
interesting to talk about mm you know I
mean but because the second photo makes
him look like a hobbit
and the first one makes them look good
this doesn't help his case as I scroll
I'll be less and less interested the
first one was pretty good he gives you
eyes and everything
the second one made him look short yeah
very short so one of the first questions
he's gonna be asked by the girls is how
tall are you
yeah that's for sure let's see how this
goes so I already put his pictures on
tinder and I invented some bio just some
simple stuff hi my name is Alex I live
and work in Lisbon as a psychologist
looking for a nice lady to develop a
meaningful relationship with and enjoy
the pleasures of life just Portuguese
port to be fair Portuguese just take
from Russian yeah there you go I got you
money you know about war history
monoghan you can see her eyebrows they
look Portuguese this is day three of
senior operation and it's going well on
the first day we only got five matches
and I was like I was stressing out I was
just like this is going to be much
harder than what I was thinking I mean I
thought this was going to be like
easy-peasy okay I'm going to take these
women and this women are going to want
to go under there with me and I'm going
to match a lot and that didn't happen on
the group of five there was one there
was that was like really gorgeous
another one that I don't know why the
hell did she matched with me I mean the
whole conversation was just pure pain
pure agony she was like answering weeds
two or three words in each message guys
after Oh wouldn't be putting their
profile if you want to talk to me have
some personality y'all have very little
to no personality I don't have an
online-dating they don't have to may
have all the goods man I told you about
that thank you I don't even joke about
it earlier but the most ironic profiles
like don't start a conversation with me
with just hi and that that I met with
started a conversation with me with just
hi I said don't ever talk to me and I
left her on red and I matched her day
later you didn't explain no no no so
cheese there's certain women online that
I'm like you're hot
I wanna smash but you annoy me to my
core so much it's more important for me
to get this thing at my chest than it is
for me to stick my finger pumping and I
was like why stop this stop I asked her
to if she wanted to go on a date we mean
she was lucky that I asked her because
she was being literally like pain you're
lucky that I would even spend a minutes
to go on a date with you cuz you were
unbearable to talk to but I will bless
you with my presence because I'm
attended yeah why day two I was blown
the way I mean I was like oh this is it
this is the real deal we got more 28
matches 28 it's a lot let's be honest
here on average those women were not
they're good-looking I'm not being
selective and I think that's a problem
here I'm just swiping like a maniac and
see what I can get swapping like a man a
maniac a man yeah I don't think I should
do that anymore I want to try a
different approach I want to be more
selective and I'm going to try to think
more like a man let me try to pick and
swipe the most beautiful women that
appear I want the more attractive ones
and I want to see that if I'm not that
selective can I get as many matches so
here's the tener accounts I don't know
exactly what this is
but this is like I think there are a lot
of women that are liking me this is like
has this is how tinder baits you maybe
like 90 women have liked you if you pay
for tinder gold you can have access and
see all the profiles of women and then
you pay for it it's a bunch of busted
ass ugly women man
yo is the dustiest girls you've ever
seen and you're like tinder trapped ask
me how I know how you know cuz I need to
match good I'm going to text her sing hi
how are you no no only the hottest dudes
can get away with hi how are you
regular dudes no that don't work well
you got to be clever you got to stand
out from the rest
women have such little attention span
there's so many matches so many guys
talking to them they're all so
disinterested in tinder in general
because they don't believe in the app so
then if you just come with them with a
mundane conversation then they don't
feel like investing themselves
emotionally so you got a stand out you
got to come in with some clever line and
they go hehehe and then you try to close
the deal as quickly as possible you want
to move your conversation from tinder to
other social media apps ASAP because the
shelf life of most women on dating apps
is very short you very for most women
date on tinder forbid delete it come
back for a short time delete it come
back for a short time most people liked
it so you better move fast bro me I tell
you when this after I've sent seven
messages and she's replied to seven by
the eighth one on my hey man and I'd
move it to other things and if the girls
like yeah I'm not really comfortable
that I'm like cool and I move on move on
so this is day five and at this point
I'm not motivated I am not happy with
the results on day three I got 13
matches yesterday I got one and today I
got one in the beginning I had lots of
matches but I wasn't actually being
selective and let's be honest here I was
matching with women that were not that
attractive I was getting like women on
mid-thirties higher what amazed me
wasn't this decreased of matches was
actually replying I mean how can I get
these women to go on a date with me if
they don't even reply to me of course
you don't have to because you ain't got
game you have all this man facade but
you still talk like a woman right so if
you come up with the hi how are you and
you're waiting for something and she's
not interested okay you have to have a
little bit of spark in the higher our
how are you it's not gonna cut it yeah
you still you're talking with who you're
trying to impress so you both have the
same MO
I'll just say this it's not because I
become a woman tomorrow that I know how
to put on makeup the same way it's not
because you become a man tomorrow that
you know have game
we gotta suffer we gotta try things we
get rejected a lot and we learn so it's
like what I said at the beginning you go
get matches but you're gonna get up cuz
you ain't got no game to be fair he also
sabotages you with those pictures I'm
serious he really did some of those
pictures were bad I was so confused I
mean if we match why aren't we talking
I met with so many and I got no response
you're not getting a response because
you don't know how to initiate how you
start a conversation especially on
tinder will indicate whether or not it
has a chance to go for it your first
impression is everything you ain't got
game I saw a lot of like Instagram stuff
follow me on Instagram and I didn't
thought this would happen I didn't
thought I would match and they wouldn't
reply from what I talked to my friends
and maybe myself that doesn't happen if
I matched like the man doesn't reply to
me like that doesn't happen if I compare
an experience that a woman has on a
dating app and that man has on a dating
app it's much different and it's weird
that I struggle so much and that if I
change like the picture to a woman I
don't struggle at all didn't thought it
would be like this because I find Alex
in terms of looks a good-looking and
interesting I put he was damn
psychologist that's super interesting I
don't know if people get depressed after
being on a dating app but I don't know I
just feel like down at this point I
don't know why I feel down it's not even
me hey sorry I am very curious to hear
how you got on have you had a good week
or a bad week with Chindi was it a
success or a failure
I think it was a failure side don't you
way better without all that lipstick mmm
I don't know how you applied or whatever
but you look great right now but maybe
it's just the different cameras
I had like lots of expectations on what
would go on and what would like happen
and it was like the complete opposite in
terms of matching I got some success but
then the replying was a nightmare I just
think it's a little bit difficult for me
to invite them to go on a date with me
if they don't even reply and this
happened like a lot a lot I don't think
I need to watch anymore yeah
there's nothing new for me how many
water is wet is it with I don't even
know I'm not even onto it and I know
because it's true for every walk of life
whenever girls have approached me it's
never been on a line that really shocked
me it's never been like wow most of
times like oh she's making the first
move that's kind of cool but I my
standard for how a girl makes the first
move is way lower you know I'm saying so
this is not surprising you know it is
what it is i watch this I was like duh
that's how I felt
what do you think what do you think
about her reaction we can't talk about
like the effect that is not surprise to
us what do think about the effect is
surprise to her not surprise that if a
surprise to her
you don't think women should know it
what we go through we're supposed to
know how they feel not the other way
around nobody gives a about man yeah how
we feel what are experiencing cares
what's experienced it's funny whenever I
talk about the man you experience four
different things and I'm like oh okay
next time you talk to me about your
experience watch how I'm gonna react
wait some girl approached me alright
some girl approached me said hey are you
a Virgo asking for a friend
you know what I said I said no I hate
astrology and I hate the city you live
in so you don't even know what city I
live in it's not anymore my profile like
yeah but I just hate wherever you are
that's how I'm going to call ya
I get bumps it's first first messages
all the time is that from tinder or
instagram doesn't matter what platform
they don't have bean
we've done some was like yeah but you
don't know lesbian girls have game no
they don't no they don't no they don't
if they're women approaching a woman
exactly when you approach a woman as a
woman the other woman is not like have
her defenses up like she does with us
it's not the same thing negative this is
stuff I knew but hey maybe this is gonna
make women realize her and thinks maybe
is gonna make them learn certain things
for me it's just like though that's why
I think I wasn't that excited about this
video thing yeah Alexander Grace if you
guys want to go check out the original
definitely go there well tell us what
you guys think in the video is water wet
we want to hear your comments if moist
[Music]